vous n'aviez jamais dimanche
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
à tatouille prix d ami magicien
américain ont envoyé un très joli cadeau
on maquille temps les cadeaux qu'il ya à
l'intérieur un truc qui permet de
retrouver deux cartes choisies deux cas
oui tu sais que normalement on retrouve
qu'une seule terre mais là on m'a donné
des coups si on va essayer en tout cas
car en tout cas il faut bien sûr d'abord
choisir deux cas d'accord de cas celle
que tu veux tu hésites bien attention tu
prends mes doigts voilà c'est fait je
peux les regarder non à mondoubleau pas
les voir mais toi tu veux bien qu'on
souvenirs chacun
d'accord je me rappellerai alors on
aimait à l'intérieur du paquet ou comme
tu veux tuer on va mélanger
de toutes les façons possibles afin que
voilà tu ne puisses pas et moi non plus
les retrouver d'accord encore quand tu
participes à tout petit petit point qui
ploie la très bien et bien pour
retrouver les deux cas précis maintenant
quelqu'un de très très gentil qui est à
l'intérieur du paquet oui les gentils
six mois à un moment là tu vas voir
quelqu'un de beaucoup plus gentils comme
ça on l'a il s'appelle margaret à
marcher clinique
c'est une k7 amoureux elle va retrouver
ma main si tu le veux bien la première
carte us à la retrouver
carette à non c'est vrai tu sais me
confronte la douceur et elle se penche
vers le jeu il ya on ne veut pas faire
une victoire si aulas si on tue la
chatterie voilà il retrouve une carte
c'est le dise de caro ancien pacha les
formidables à tout ça et bien et coûtent
maintenant on va essayer la deuxième
carte mais quand même là il est inscrit
sur sa petite boîte qu'on peut faire
quelque chose de plus difficile en
plaçant un bandeau je vois à bratton oui
bien sûr elles voient plus rien du tout
allende a retrouvé pourtant la deuxième
carte choisie allons margaret regarder
le tremblement 6-1 2-3 à un ordi dont
des mondes war aux méchins ce qui est
une preuve qu'il ne vois vraiment rien
du tout alors encore une fois et elle
retrouve une carte c'est le 5
non le cadre de pique c'était ça ou eh
ben dis donc tu sais pourquoi je vais te
le dire mais tu ne répétera pas elle a
l'air très gentils comme ça mais ma
qu'un défaut margaret triche c'est vrai
elle regarde bien de l'autre côté tu
veux elles arriveront dans son bandeau
envoya le voyait chez leur plaisir à
ceux ci de marque a été bien mignonne
un sucre de canne
hop
m
[Musique]
le
on
[Musique]
oui
je
m
[Musique]
où
bonjour non aujourd'hui david et adeline
nuls 11 ans mais non mais non content de
nous et nous et on était là à dongo où
il a fait une halte à vous défendre
non on a deux noms revenus la nuque ou
trouver une nounou publier ou non d'un
contrat et non grimés mais fédérer
[Musique]
non
ro
[Musique]
en
vous
à
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire pascal
c'est vrai charme et et il est parmi
nous un alors là ça tombe bien je
connais j'ai vous montrer comment on
peut fabriquer avec une vieille
casserole vous prenez bien soin de votre
corps mais un gâteau d'anniversaire
magic touch carton pour votre vie si ça
paraît incroyable mais pour ça il faut
de la farine contre pas partout
attention c'est une farine magix une
farine en feuilles vous avez jamais vu
ça regardez on dirait on dirait presque
du papier ainsi longtemps c'est une fin
remercier les fans alors la farine en
feuilles on ne la fait pas chauffée de
la manière classique mettant de l'eau
tout ça en jouant du moment une autre
façon de simone on prend un briquet et
on allume directement voyez comme cela
alors voyez ça va coller et même très
dangereux parce que j'ai promis
abracadabra et rabat également à
regarder
il ya un splendide gâteau des bâtons
c'est un gâteau avec la chanson est ce
qu ont fait les gâteaux subi dimanche un
décret avant ma mort la recette mais de
toute façon pendant a quand même étudié
on n'est pas là pour rigoler seulement
attention un intrus gear a montré un
truc avec des cartes à jouer journée le
gâteau tout à l'heure on le mange tout à
l'heure alors voilà une carte est placée
contre la main vous l'appelez avec le
push et là hop en place comme ceux ci
des cartes envoyées entre le lecteur tu
que j'aimais au départ et la main afin
quand vous voudrez vous placez les
cartes contre la masse afin libre à
taille
oui sa fin des regrets mais si je retire
mon pouce évidemment les cartes vont
tomber
on va essayer attention à sa tâche est
incertain
doucement je retire ma bouche mais j'ai
la main tu étais là et est maintenant
attention et ça tombe rien ne tombe
rien ne tombe à mâcher alors le kart
reste suspendue comme cela après il ya
un truc bien sûr et le truc vous allez
le découvrir vous même sens que je vous
l'expliqué regarder la plupart des
cartes
si je les retire ton normalement et une
carte reste 26 jours les doazit je ne
tiens pas pourquoi et maintenant c'est
pas de la colle regardez c'est un fils
hanouna elle pense que j'ai fixé avec du
ruban adhésif derrière la carte
donc on ne voit pas et l'autre extrémité
du filet relier est attaché à ma
ceinture alors si je place le file entre
les doigts
la carte pas mais si ensuite je tire un
petit peu évidemment elle vient se
coincer contre la main alors si on tend
bien fort on peut placer les cartes
entre cette carte qui est attaché au lit
et la main évidemment si on lâche sa
tombe mais si on tient bien elle ça
reste 110 candidats à huy toujours très
bien alors d'ailleurs parce qu'à la
moindre des choses puisque c'est ton
anniversaire jeu de montrer à ses amis
pour le repas d'anniversaire le gâteau
qu'on appellerait se tourne elle veut le
faire tourner je regarde mes cartons
carton avec des pièces métalliques
dessus voyez des tuyères des petits
réveil il ya un réveil
oui une cuillère une casserole un trio
de musiciens il ya un choix à faire
c'est assez bizarre c'est que des objets
métalliques des dents et pourquoi alors
vous allez tout de suite le savoir
c'est ce qui fait que ce qu'ils
cherchent un aimant policiers pour des
gros coups celui-là alors on met en
place sans cet aimant au dessus des
pièces mécaniques henry remplaçant assez
bien on peut arriver
on va les faire tony h alors est par
contre si j'enlève les mois j'ai compris
j'ai une règle a pas 4 je vais essayer
de profiter des leçons pascal parce que
là il ya une chose intéressante gars tu
veux dire que si on place une carte jeu
contre la main grâce à un petit peu de
l'effet magnétique qui y en existe
sûrement pas mais on peut donner cette
illusion on laisse une carte et la
regarde elle tout tu vois et oui
pourtant il n'y a rien du tout tu es
compris james bond là ya pas de fil on
va saint gérard
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
que ça mais non là ce petit bonhomme
voilà vous je te laisse ici mais
méfie-toi de à ce sont d'affreux persona
du tout non non j'ai pas du tout
confiance en elle et autonome
[Musique]
le téléphone assez pour toi nicolas mais
toi ici tu va écouter dans le duo temps
pour être isolés dans valises à laisser
ça comme c'est beaucoup mieux pour toi
écoute bien tuyaux nicolas
[Musique]
descola
les amis aussi on vous demande au
téléphone nous et vous téléphone la
salle et téléphone allô allô
à l'approché toi
[Musique]
à
ah ah
et
[Musique]